we have exciting news today we're
launching another new channel and I
think you're gonna like it we get tons
of emails from fans and we try our best
to read and check everyone's work as
they send it in which is not easy well
we met someone named couch tomato who
sent us his channel with 12 subscribers
it was brand new but we saw some really
great potential in what he was doing we
started working with him to develop the
look and format and we gets turned into
something awesome so now we're excited
to launch couch tomato as a new addition
to our family of channels this guy
thinks like we do now nothing is going
to change on the main channel this new
channel will be run by the couch tomato
himself we thought we'd put the first
one here on the main channel to give it
a bit of exposure and if you liked this
video you can see more at the link in
the description this movies about this
one guy who's a real loner he keeps to
himself but later on he meets this girl
dressed in all black and she's
mysterious and stuff
she turns his whole world upside down
and things get real weird so much so
that he ends up getting questioned by
some dude in uniform are here on the guy
asking him questions start off on the
wrong foot they can't stand each other
you could tell they probably want to
kick each other's butts right now but
they have to wait into this later scene
in the movie that takes place on a train
track before it even gets to that point
main hero gets saved by the girl in
black and they take a car right together
he ends up entering this new world after
going through this hole to meet some of
the other supporting characters there's
this prophecy dude
see there's this whole story about how
good use diverse evil and then evil
started winning and enslaving the good
but luckily some of the good escaped and
live in hiding in a wait the day when
the chosen one will rescue them all the
prophecy dude is - dude that thinks that
our main character is the chosen one
spoken in the prophecy since no one can
truly be the one without optimal
training prophecy guy taps into the
heroes head for training exercises
it starts off well until something
happens where the alleged chosen one is
put on display in front of all of his
new friends and fails miserably
embarrassing later on during a meeting
with his friends the bad guy uses a
tracking device to trace the good guys
whereabouts police ambush the entire
operation and it doesn't look good not
only do the bad guys manage to whip some
buttocks but they raised the stakes
after they managed to turn this into a
hostage situation
no worries as the chosen one comes up
with a plan to infiltrate the skyscraper
bad guy headquarters they get past
security without breaking a sweat timing
is of the essence as the hostage or
hostages
getting their brains tortured to give up
some valuable Intel sadly the good guy
dies with no one to stand in his way
the bad guy since these metallic
sentinel spider leg looking thing is to
go after our survivors it looks really
bad until the good guy CPR is himself
back to life and rejoins the fight looks
like the rest of them some good because
when he comes back we find that he's
conveniently upgraded this fighting
technique the one guy in the two-piece
suit blows up after that all the
metallic spider lag looking thingy
simultaneously go down for the count and
the two lovebirds live happily ever
after those are 24 reasons these movies
are the same you agree Yes No maybe so
if not politely share your thoughts in
the comment section below subscribe to
the couch tomato here for more 24
reasons videos believe me you are going
to be surprised at the connections he
finds